it's noodles it's an iconic step naughty
only in India but across Asia the staple
is a comfort food for one of us and this
really is Nestle's make it or break a
moment of what they're going to do next
the moment of truth for the company
moving forward this is a snack as we
talked about mothers have been feeding
their kids for three decades and this
iconic Maggie instant noodle itself and
think most of us do recognize that
yellow packaging and this routine test
came from a small town supermarket first
that deliver that shocking result and
there were other tests done in Delhi as
well that found again those lead
contamination they're still exceeding
government regulations so this really
has jolted the nation Angie take a look
the shares in Mumbai yesterday plunging
nine percent for nestle india it is a
steepest fall in nine years retailers
have halted sales of the instant noodle
future group which is one of India's
biggest supermarket chains they stopped
taking it off the shelves in nearly 500
stores Walmart 220 of its wholesale sore
stores and there are criminal complaints
now against nestle india including the
Bollywood stars that endorse the branham
you know and commercials may be facing
charges as well are they criminally I
guess they were part of the advertising
of this the false advertising possibly
we will see what happens in that front
but again India Food regulators saying
that they are going to be conducting
testing in all of these products as well
in 28 states in India all of its states
here but state saying they're not
waiting we're doing our own testing
Delhi themselves banning the sales of
those Maggie insta noodles for 15 days I
mean the public response has been almost
immediate and and alarming how has the
company responded at this point they are
denying the results of some of these
tests they said they've done their own
testing tested a thousand samples all
results show that the lead levels
they're well within levels that are
lawful on its website it's also saying
that they're working with authorities
are doing more testing doing some damage
control but still maintaining the
noodles are safe to eat